c'est la grande question cette semaine
taux fixe ou variable vous avez été très
nombreux à nous poser la question alors
que la banque du canada a clairement
signalé son intention de hausser encore
les taux d'intérêt les taux pourraient
monter rapidement du moins à un rythme
qu'on n'a pas vue depuis longtemps pour
des conseils on a nos côtés et denis du
seil et directeur de la formation du
courtier hypothécaire multi-prêts
bonsoir monsieur doucet soit alors
rarement la banque du canada a été aussi
claire on dit qu'on vise tons neutres
deux et demi à trois et demi pour cent
dans un horizon quand même assez course
c'est pour le taux directeur
qu'est ce que ça va vouloir dire pour
les taux hypothécaires pour les taux
hypothécaires variables les marges de
crédit hypothécaires
c'est sûr que ça va suivre l'évolution
de la banque du canada
non mais quand on dit rapidement la
banque sur l'industrie unis à toutes les
six semaines puis évidemment ça sera pas
une hausse de 1% la fois donc ça va
s'échelonner quand même sur une période
qui est pour pour nous préparer paraître
courte mais il reste c'est quand même
plusieurs mois la rencontre la teigne
pour ceux qui sont en taux variable
les taux les taux fixes plutôt les taux
fixes e very déjà depuis de plusieurs je
dirais de plusieurs semestre
c'est moins précis moins annoncée pour
une conférence de presse la banque du
canada pour dire que ça augmente donc à
ce moment là ça ne crée pas la même et
qui est je pense que cette semaine ce
qui était inquiétant c'est l'assurance
avec laquelle le gouverneur a dit que
oui va avoir une hausse de taux ça s'en
vient préparez vous ces nouvelles
l'avait été en 2009 aussi quand que la
banque du canada avait diminué
rapidement les taux il disait regardez
c'est pour six mois puis par la suite on
va augmenter puis selon les paramètres
économiques finalement la hausse a été
beaucoup plus lente que prévu
l'automnale l'acquis de l'économie voit
très bien les
et de l'emploi va très bien mais est-ce
que ça durera encore pour six mois un an
deux infos voir puis je pense que la
banque sonata au fur et à mesure
réévaluent en fonction des indicateurs
économiques et décide qu est ce qui est
le plus approprié
mais je pense que là dedans la question
c'est le rythme de l'augmentation parce
qu'il est clair qu'on se dirige vers une
hausse des taux d'intérêt pour les
prochains mois tout est loin et ça n'est
pas concret pour les finances le budget
des emprunteurs on a un exemple
d'ailleurs à vous proposer un emprunt de
200 mille dollars amortie sur 25 ans
avant la hausse ce qui a été annoncé
cette semaine si vous aviez le meilleur
taux à 2,6 pour cent s'est donné un
versement mensuel d'à peu près 9 105
dollars après l'augmentation 931 dollars
donc une augmentation quoi de 25 $ il ya
quand même une pression là oui c'est sûr
et c'est la cinquième en 15 mois donc
et à chaque fois c'est un 25 dollars de
plus que qu'évidemment pour les gens qui
avaient emprunté mettons dans les
limites permises par les taux de
qualification avec évidemment pour eux
ça peut créer un problème et a eu ce
qu'on peut leur dire c'est si vous
sentez qu'un problème s'en vient
consulter tout de suite des
professionnels pour éviter d'accumuler
de vous retrouver dans un problème dans
une situation plus problématique pour
les gens qui étaient en fixe de toute
façon ça changera rien parce que
vainement mais si c'est déjà depuis
plusieurs plusieurs moments plusieurs
que quelques années que au
renouvellement il y avait des
ajustements de taux qui était pas énorme
mais qui étaient là quand même
puis les gens juste et leurs budgets en
conséquence la ce moment de ce marché
cela dit historiquement du moins dans
l'histoire récente on était souvent
gagnant de prendre un trou variable est
ce que vous diriez que c'est encore le
cas aujourd'hui mais toutes les études
sur une période de 25 ans disent que le
taux variable coûte moins cher en
intérêts et ceci a été démontré de
plusieurs façons aujourd'hui si on
contracte un taux variable on pourrait
la voir à 2.75 kills est un phénomène
c'était 2 et 60 au début de la semaine
les
le taux de référence a augmenté de
points 25 et pourtant les taux variables
ont augmenté de points 15 seulement on
prélève à 2.612 15 alors qu'un taux fixe
un canon pour la vente à 3.5 dans les
moeurs
donc il ya déjà un écart favorable en
faveur du taux variable mais s'est
associé à un risque de changement et le
je pense que les gens quand il ya un
visage de taux variable ou qui partent
vraiment qu'ils pensent en termes de
leur capacité de supporter un changement
ou une augmentation de 25 50 $
qu'est ce qui arrive que des gens ça va
les empêcher de dormir son mandat lisait
qu'un taux fixes des premiers acheteurs
souvent on vous la recommande un taux
fixe parce qu'il commence en plus de
dépenses et plus sécure de de cette
façon là quand c'est facile de fixer un
taux on peut faire ça rapidement est ce
que les pénalités dépend de comment
contrer fait comme un lac de près effet
de transférer ça peut être fait à
n'importe quel mot m quand vous avez
l'option de pouvoir convertir en taux
fixe ça peut se faire
c'est juste que les modalités des
institutions financières ne sont pas
n'ont pas les mêmes modalités
dans certains cas ça vaut la peine dans
d'autres courses ça coûte presque chaque
gardé son prêt variable
cela dit quand même une bonne majorité
d'emprunteurs qui comme vous le
mentionnez choisissent un taux fixe en
général mais le taux fixe de cinq ans
ferme et pour ceux qui doivent
renouveler dont la prochaine année là
est ce que ça vaut la peine d'aller voir
l'institution financière de négocier
disons en amont est ce qu'il ya des
pénalités pour faire ça encore le ça va
dépendre des intentions financières des
décisions financières qui vont accepter
même ton est ce mot-là à la danse de
renouveler sans frais il y en a d'autres
qui ont un prix imposé des frais
d'administration ou parfois ça peut être
des pénalités s'est laissé un peu la
discrétion ce n'est pas réglementée
cette partie donc c'est un peu la
discrétion d'un sillon financière que le
système financier est en concurrence
quand même puis évidemment une question
financière qui voit que peut-être une
occasion d'aller chercher de nouveaux
clients
des fois ils vont faire des petits
accommodements pour réussir à avoir
liquidé il nous reste quelques secondes
monsieur doucet ce que vous pensez que
ça va freiner le marché immobilier avec
cette pression accrue
on avait cette crainte le l'an dernier
quand les premières eaux sont arrivés
l'année
et 2000 2018 a eu quand même beaucoup
d'activité de revente et nous ce qu'on a
constaté c'est que les gens qui avaient
peut-être plus de difficultés à
emprunter un des plus gros montants ont
choisi autre chose donc au lieu de
compromettre le projet et ont relocalisé
dans une autre région ou sortir de
montréal jusqu'à prix ça voilà c'est
toujours du cas par cas
mais si douce et merci beaucoup
bienvenue